facebook officially suspended president
trump's facebook account
for the next two years why because he's
a risk
to public safety the decision comes as
the tech giant announced it would no
longer exempt politicians from
moderation rules
making it easier for the site to delete
content from politicians they don't like
remember when mark zuckerberg said
facebook wouldn't be an arbiter for
political speech
apparently he doesn't remember that
either joining me now author of the
madness of crowds
douglas murray douglas thanks so much
for coming on great to be with you
it really concerns me to see a decision
like this happen
when you see the power of facebook to
shut down the ability of a
elected leader of the united states to
communicate with his fans in
in a way like this it really raises
concerns to me about political speech
going forward
what's your response to this exertion of
big tech power
yes mark zuckerberg sent out one of his
vice presidents the vice president for
global affairs
a man called nick clegg who today
announced
that we believe his donald trump's
actions
constitute a severe violation of our
rules which merit the highest
penalty available uh many of your
viewers uh will be wondering who this
creep and [ __ ] is i know
uh i've followed creep and [ __ ] nick
clegg for many years
he used to be our deputy prime minister
in the country of my birth great britain
uh he was chucked out by the british
electorate uh because he was wildly
unpopular he was then chucked out by his
own constituents so he wasn't even in
the house of commons
but now he gets to say what a former
president of the united states can
say where and when so in some ways i
congratulate him
for his enormous global upgrade from
total failure
in his land of birth to deciding who can
say what across the globe it's an
amazing amazing promotion
yes it's quite the achievement i mean
there's an audacity to it
uh that's amazing when i when i look at
this type of decision
it makes me concerned about the future
but it also makes me
you know aware i think the degree to
which we can no longer trust
these type of entities these
corporations uh to seek out
the public interest when it comes to
simply being able to communicate with
politicians
do you think that there's a slippery
slope from here that's going to lead to
increasing problems with
adjudicating over and over again what
violates what rules based on who's
offended by what
elected politicians say it's we're
already on it we're way down it
uh these companies that uh assume the
right to decide what you
and i and all of us can know read and
say
are nowhere near up for the job my own
view is that absolutely nobody could be
but they're especially not up for the
job they're especially unqualified
they talk about free speeches and as if
nobody thought about it until
a seminar they had some time last
semester
i mean we're dealing with kids here and
when we see them
talking about our language and our
rights and our ideas and our permission
to exchange ideas across america across
politics across the world
it's very very sinister what they're
doing let's remember as melissa chen was
saying in your previous segment
i mean these companies got everything
about the last year wildly wrong we just
discovered a new one
which is it was a lab league issue for
the last year
facebook twitter all of these
panjandrums
of deciding what we can know and say uh
decided the lab leak was a total
conspiracy theory
so now they've got to turn that one
around they're not fit for purpose they
don't know what they're doing
and it's high time that we the citizenry
made it clear that we
cannot and will not live under the rules
of big
tech they're not up to the job that
they've taken it upon their shoulders
to try to perform it's it is really
insulting to me that uh
mark zuckerberg now occupies a more
powerful position in america than
the pope in rome douglas murray thank
you so much for taking the time to join
me tonight